eine entführung einer der gefährlichsten
städte der welt in der irakischen
hauptstadt bagdad ist die deutsche
kulturvermittlerin heller mevis
verschleppt worden und darüber möchte
ich jetzt sprechen mit burn stritzel
denn es gibt ein video das aufgetaucht
ist dieses soll die entführung zeigen
genau dieses video wurde gestern abend
in irakischen whatsapp gruppen geteilt
zeigt wie eine person auf einer straße
angehalten wird von zwei fahrzeugen eine
von einem kleinen video einem weißen
kleinen pick up truck und dann von
bewaffneten männern in diesen in diesem
pickup gezwängt wird und das deckt sich
mit dem mit dem was zeugen erzählt haben
über den über die entführung über die
verschleppung von hella mieves das video
wurde noch nicht verifiziert recht genau
das ist sozusagen eine wenn das leaking
offizielle veröffentlichung
es ist noch nicht verifiziert nicht
bestätigt ob es sich dabei tatsächlich
handelt und es gibt auch ein paar
anhaltspunkte die darauf hindeuten dass
es vielleicht was anderes sein könnte
was anderes zeigen könnte unter anderem
ist das können wir uns hier nicht sehen
da timecode der überwachungskamera deckt
sich nicht genau mit dem zeitpunkt der
der entführung das kann allerdings
natürlich auch an den
kameraeinstellungen liegen
allerdings muss man dazu sagen dass es
im irak nicht unüblich ist dass solche
dass solche videos von den
überwachungskameras die irgendwelche
kriminalfälle zeigen gelegt werden also
das ist da ist auch relativ üblich als
vor zwei wochen ein bekannter irakischer
analyst vor seinem haus in einem in
einem ähnlichen szenario getötet wurde
tatsächlich gab es auch ein paar stunden
später wurden die videos der
überwachungskameras veröffentlicht
gibt es schon indizien wer hinter der
entführung stecken könnte also in die
zehn jahre lang nie was muss man dazu
wissen war er als kulturvermittlerin
tätig hat sich mit einer jungen
irakischen generation mit künstlern sehr
gut verstanden oder bewegte sich in
diesen kreisen die im vergangenen herbst
gegen die korruption im irak ging hier
vorherrschende
banden herrschaft schiitisch islamische
milizen demonstrierte und
naheliegenderweise ist sie auch deshalb
ins fadenkreuz dieser milizen gerückt
ein weiteres indiz was darauf hindeutet
ist dass das gestern der sogenannte
sicherheitschef von einer dieser milizen
von der kts dollar
aber ali al askari ja eine stellungnahme
abgegeben hat in der er den irakischen
premierminister seinen politischen
gegner beschuldigt hinter der entführung
zu stecken was völlig absurd ist also ja
und das ist ja eines dieser üblichen
ablenkungsmanöver dieser schiitischen
miliz die hat sehr wahrscheinlich auch
vor zwei wochen hinter der entführung
dieses japanischen terror analysten
steckt von dem ich gesprochen habe
da hat sie auch da haben ihre
sympathisanten dann auch gleich die
absurdesten verschwörungstheorien in die
welt gesetzt und dass er da jetzt auch
schon wieder so proaktiv den irakischen
premierminister beschuldigt das deutet
darauf hin dass seine miliz oder leute
aus seinem umfeld mit dieser entführung
mit dieser entführung zu tun haben
was genau machen jetzt die deutschen
behörden um diese erwerben diese
entführung aufzuklären um sie wieder
zurück zu bekommen
also ich nehme mir vor allem an dass sie
in kontakt stehen mit den irakischen
sicherheitsbehörden dass diejenigen die
also die das irakische innenministerium
hat bestätigt dass eine sonderkommission
gebildet wurde aus nachrichtendiensten
aus geheimen aus geheimdienstkreisen aus
kriminal ermittlern die aufspüren soll
wo wohin am iwes verschleppt wurde
wohin sie verschleppt wurde und für alle
natürlich von wem und ich nehme an dass
man da auch schon eine gewisse spur hat
ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher wenn wir
wie lange eine solche miliz tatsächlich
jemanden verschleppen kann in einem ja
in einer stadt wie bagdad die von
informanten durchsetzt ist und wo
natürlich auch das innenministerium mit
seinen beziehungen zu diesen milizen
wenn wir davon ausgehen dass ein solcher
ist über kurz oder lang wahrscheinlich
in erfahrung bringen wird wo diese sein
wird und natürlich wird das damit den
deutschen behörden geteilt